this video is brought to you by keeps
what's up guys
Jared here to talk to you about
something that's as American as
canceling your Amazon Prime trial
immediately after getting two-day
shipping on a Nintendo switch I'm
talking about the art of convincing you
to buy stuff advertising occupies a
strange place in our collective
imagination we revile it when it
interrupts our beloved YouTube videos we
talk about it way too much when it's
Super Bowl season and frequently ignore
it unless it features kendall Jenner
single-handedly ending racism but what
if we told you that advertising aside
from being an annoying interrupter of
content shaped America in ways you never
imagined possible
want to know how stick around for this
wisecrack edition on how advertising
changed America and appropriately enough
for a video about ads we want to thank
heaps for sponsoring this video
spending all this time at home I've had
a chance to reflect on myself there are
some things I want to work on and some
things that I don't want to change for
example I never want to lose my hair and
would do anything to prevent it after
all the key to combating hair loss is
prevention keeps makes it easy because
they offer fda-approved over-the-counter
and prescription medication and deliver
it right to your front door the process
is so easy you simply meet with an
online doctor and get the medication
shipped to your home keeps works to save
the hair that you have and some men even
experience hair regrowth find out why
keeps has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors and why nearly
100,000 men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication by clicking
the link in the description or by going
to keeps calm / wisecrack if you use our
link you can get 50% off your first
order so stop stressing and keep your
hair and now back to the show
advertising as we know it is somewhat of
a newcomer in society's development
prior to the invention of the printing
press for instance when most people were
illiterate advertising mostly took the
form of symbols like an anvil signifying
that you were a blacksmith if you walk
through a public square you would often
be accosted by enterprising peddlers and
public friars who spread news about
product shipments theatrical
performances and more as time went on as
scholar Julian Savola explains in her
book soap sex and cigarettes advertising
continued to reflect the cultural and
technological realities of the time
naturally when the printing press came
around in the 15th century it led to an
explosion in literacy and soon at the
emergence of printed ads newspapers
became widespread in the 1600s and by
the 1700s were all aboard the ad train
but the big campaigns you associate with
Campbell Soup or coca-cola were nowhere
to be seen that is until a little thing
called America happened and I don't mean
America's endless thirst for cocaine
juice English entrepreneurs in the 17th
and 18th century tried luring people to
the new world with the promise of free
land in exchange for labor in what was
one of the first concerted and sustained
advertising campaigns in the history of
the modern world according to historian
Richard Hofstadter the ads are mostly
lost to time but the sentiment can be
seen in engravings of the time which
typically and creepily embodied America
as an indian queen in a lush landscape
ads accordingly presented America as a
Garden of Eden full of gold and
fountains of youth and abundant land but
this successful plan had one minor
hiccup America was a total sausage party
with men outnumbering women's six to one
in Virginia and Maryland the Virginia
company stepped in with of course an ad
campaign addressing this lack they've
literally give you a wife in exchange
for a hundred and twenty pounds of
decent tobacco because you know romance
but otherwise a rural developing America
didn't generally have much use for
advertising at the time most Americans
lived in self-sustaining farms where
they produced everything they needed
still there were some ads and it's very
important and depressing to note that a
large percentage of them were
advertising rewards for black people who
had escaped slavery this was only the
beginning of an extremely ugly history
of racism and advertising full of
disturbing imagery we're not going to
show you because but in the early 1800s
sweeping change is about to transform
the country and it's advertising for
good cue the first Industrial Revolution
suddenly manufacturers were able to make
products so cheaply that it costs less
to buy lots of your household goodies
than to make them as a new network of
railroads and waterways began to snake
around the country shipping costs fell
also growing urbanization meant fewer
people
growing food meaning they had to
actually buy it around this time
crafting advertisements started to
become a real profession though not
quite Don Draper Swank a fine yet
Americans were consuming more but our
country wasn't primarily driven by
consumer spending not yet at least
it would take the Civil War to really
turn American consumption into the
engine of our economy
so volca cites two central reasons that
changed the entire economy first the war
mainstreamed factory made food and
clothing amongst hundreds of thousands
of soldiers with us rendering them more
willing to buy say mass-produced suits
or canned goods in the future and second
with all the men at war women now had to
pick up the slack in the fields and at
the factories leaving them less time for
their household tasks like cooking
sewing and soap making advertisements at
the time weren't very sophisticated
mostly relying on the hard sell style of
advertising which is all about capturing
the consumers attention in
straightforward ways telling them why
they need your product and why it's the
best this can be particularly seen in
patent medicine ads of the time which
often hard sold solutions that just
didn't work patent medicine and medical
quackery skyrocketed from the end of the
Civil War until the end of the century
becoming one third of all American
publishers revenue by the turn of the
century this was in part because so many
wounded soldiers became addicted to
wartime drugs which included cocaine and
opium also lousy diets lots of disease
and increased settlement out west meant
more people didn't have access to a
trained doctor so why not try cass
Koretz Candi cathartic patent medicine
salesman also predicted another
increasingly important aspect of
advertising packaging you know the stuff
surrounding your new purchase that you
promptly discard
cheap mass production of packaging
materials after the Civil War doesn't
sound like the most exciting thing in
the world but trust us it changed the
game completely it allowed for brand
differentiation and ushered in a host of
new marketing techniques including
trademarks instead of buying a plain
barrel of oatmeal people were
increasingly saving their money for
brand named goods based solely on
packaging and branding exemplified by
the Quaker Oats guy who was born around
this time
but advertisers had a growing problem
they'd have to face a lot of Americans
wary of tacky pet and medicine ads found
mass consumption and the advertising
that fueled it dishonest and distasteful
so in the final decades of the 19th
century advertisers tried to rebrand
consumerism as a force of progress ads
began spotlighting the power of the
consumer to contribute to American
Progress specifically by choosing the
right products a piano for your budding
booze water the right soap that would
make you into a better mother or the
stove polish that would get you into the
Congress no real this fit right in with
the political values of the time which
celebrated morality and efficiency many
a successful advertising campaign
piggybacked off of technological reforms
of the time which did everything from
mainstream electricity to improve public
transit this certainly wouldn't be the
last time advertisers exploited
political values to overcome consumer
skepticism political values aside the
turn of the 20th century saw the rise of
the mass-produced luxury good product
you probably can't afford that you
hadn't heard of until you saw a
compelling ad consumers needed to be
educated about these new products and
why they needed them a prime example was
the Kodak camera a novelty which brought
the art of photography to the home in
1888 you can see the advertiser trying
to soothe the unfamiliar aspiring selfie
taker with the slogan you press the
button we do the rest another luxury
product of the era was the bicycle which
early ads educated consumers on how they
even worked in the first place once the
product generated a craze however
advertisers switched to depicting fun
countryside sporty enjoyment and pretty
women at the turn of the century
advertisers had solidified their
strategy into two major schools of
thought one the a fermented hard sell or
here's why you need this can opener then
to the soft side or atmospheric edge
which promised that buying a new piano
would give you the luxurious lifestyle
you've been chasing as we'll see
advertisers would often hibbett
depending on how healthy or absolutely
screwed the economy was let's start with
the good times in the 20s production
double as once thrifty Americans started
buying expensive products by installment
all ad people had to do was come up with
creative ways to separate folks from
their money and boy did they succeed
lifestyle and leisure
ads reigned supreme portraying the
message that consuming wasn't about
buying what you needed to survive it was
about buying what you wanted to enhance
your status ad maker stress this through
their frequent portrayals of upper-class
women who indulged in the fashions of
the time and not just fashionable
clothes Savile connotes that in this age
manufacturers began using color and
designed to sell everything from box to
silverware to underwear and the process
she writes manufacturers transformed
utilitarian staples into fashion goods
you'll need a hat and handbag to match
your new shoes and so on not only did
advertisers invent reasons you needed
different handbags to match your
different shoes they invented all kinds
of other weird reasons you needed to buy
their stuff hilariously cool
advertisements shamed women by inventing
fake medical terms like halitosis ie bad
breath and warning them that they would
be often a bridesmaid but never a bride
unless they bought breath deodorant this
is also around the time where razor
manufacturers decided to double their
market by convincing women that they
needed to shave their legs and pits but
a problem comes with economic growth how
do you get people to buy even more SHhhh
after your consumer buys one toaster
they may not need another one for years
or decades and that's not good for
business so advertisers invent even more
kinds of soft selling in the 1950s
manufacturers began employing dynamic
obsolescence a nicer term for planned
obsolescence that focused on design and
colors whereas in the past you might
have kept your toaster for all ten years
of its functionality you would out to
start it in favor of a cuter hipper
toaster and do so with a smile in the
wake of America's new economic power
this strategy helped foster the
strongest consumer economy we'd ever
seen this was a time when consumers
bought things on credit and they were
encouraged to own two cars several
television sets and to shop excessively
color towels and handbags weren't enough
anymore the central status symbol of the
time was a modern kitchen with the new
colored appliances doubling as fashion
statements the rising prominence of
psychology also gave advertisers some
new tools to work with
April's subconscious cue motivation
research or MRR which employed similar
psycho analytical tools used by father
of Public Relation
Edward Bernays as early as the 1920s
motivation research tried to figure out
why people bought things on both the
subconscious and unconscious level
suggesting that consumers don't actually
know what they want and said seek out
items for two main motivators sex and
security as a result bra ads tried to
tap into woman's supposed exhibitionist
tendencies while Camel cigarettes wooed
them with doctors assurances that
smoking was good for you skip ahead to
the 1980s and you'll see a consumer
market much like the 1950s but on lots
of cocaine people didn't just want to
keep up with the Joneses they wanted to
blow them out of the water
advertisers were all about reaching the
ultra consumer who drank Perrier more
Ralph Lauren and drove her Mercedes
ultra consumers also worked their butts
off in pursuit of nice things
leaving alka-seltzer to make a
commercial promising relief for the
stress of success of course prosperity
can't last forever and advertisers have
repeatedly over the twentieth century
had to relearn how to sell to thrifty
folks this occurred most notably after
the collapse of the stock market in 1929
cue the hard sell but make it mean many
1930s had scraped by openly on existing
emotions like guilt fear shame blame ads
warned mothers of the perils of not
buying their children milk and urged men
to buy Fleischmann's yeast cakes or risk
being a failure again in 1975
advertisers would be faced with the
quandary of selling to people who didn't
have much money after another recession
naturally they revived the Great
Depression style hard sell aggression
especially through monotonous repetition
as savolta puts it creativity had turned
into a rational quantifiable science
with ads less interested in fashion or
lifestyle than in convincing consumers
that their products would get the job
done even when pocketbooks were liked
advertisers came in heavy of course
there's one decade that doesn't quite
fit the mold of boom and bust era
advertising the 1960s somewhere too how
in the 1890s advertisers had to appeal
to progress to make up for the bad rap
marketing had gotten sixties advertisers
had to deal with open hostility to
consumerism brought on by counterculture
and hippies so to not seem like some
kind of lame stiff advertising embraced
creativity liberation and sticking
the man this is best exemplified by one
of the decades most famous campaigns
that of the VW Beetle these ads were
creative self-deprecating and emphasize
the unchanging nature of the VW soon
advertisers started targeting the youth
with psychedelic imagery and younger
models they also convinced the
generation of people ie boomers who
allegedly care about planet Earth to
embrace disposable everything from
blow-up furniture to pop art ceramics
advertisers also piggybacked off the
burgeoning movement for civil rights and
women's rights incorporating or if
you're cynical like us arguably co-opted
their messaging into advertising but we
haven't talked about the two gigantic
leaps in advertising technology
television and the Internet commercial
broadcasting began in the 1940s and by
1960 advertisers could reach nearly
every American home via the boob tube
but at first TV advertising looked a lot
different than it does today early
television programming was largely
controlled entirely by their sponsors
for example I Love Lucy was owned by
Philip Morris one of the first TV hits
was the Texaco Star Theater which both
opened and closed on a shot of for
Texaco gas station worker singing this
was all fine and good until the
trademark 50s Network quiz shows
revealed to be rigged by advertisers who
kept popular contestants on the show
longer in order to earn more money
networks and advertisers alike soon
renounced entirely sponsored content and
instead adopted commercial breaks we
have come to know and hate relaxed
regulation on advertisers in the 1980s
also meant the introduction of
infomercials which allow your
advertisement to go on and on and on
also increasingly ads became embedded in
movies and TV shows by a increasing use
of product placements thus further
blurring the line between entertainment
and advertising which brings us to the
internet a whole new way for advertisers
to capture people's attention if they
can only get them to click and as we'll
see that weird lack of distinction
between advertisement and content seen
in the Texaco Star Theater will really
and truly haunt us we have to start with
the beginning the banner ad and the
pop-up ad which redirected you to the
typically very janky homepage of a mega
corporation early internet advertising
worked hard to differentiate the ad from
the
her website content highly effective at
first the first banner ad for AT&T in
1994 got 44% of viewers to click on it
but we're soon dismissed as boring and
ineffective today fewer than 0.1% of
users click on a given banner ad unlike
TV the Internet has always been a tricky
place to advertise because consumers are
in control over what they interact with
or are willing to sit through but in the
new millennium advertisers would go from
wanting to get your attention to wanting
to get something more your heart and the
2000s advertising got really personal
with brands wanting to form
relationships with their consumers the
product itself becomes increasingly
irrelevant and sometimes even invisible
like this is an advertisement for
Cadbury
what's more the rise of social media
created new ways for consumers to
interact with brands which has been
exploited to varying usually humorous
and troubling degrees brands will now
just straight-up try to act like people
the goal is if you feel fondly about the
Olive Garden's social media presence
it's a lot more likely that you're not
just gonna buy a basket of breadsticks
you're going to be the envy of your
friends and buy a freaking pasta pass it
wasn't just brands trying to connect
with you on a personal level
advertisements themselves became
personalized we saw the rise of targeted
ads which required consumer surveillance
often on the part of online mega giants
like Google and Facebook with
increasingly intricate profiles of each
user based on search history
demographics and interests probably the
biggest development of the time though
is the way advertising has become
increasingly stealthy on the internet
banner ads and pop-ups were largely
replaced with search advertising in big
part thanks to Google's invention of
Adsense in 2003 which allows any web
publisher to host cost per click
contextual ads based on Google's search
history this can obviously make it more
difficult to distinguish between real
search results and promoted sites
another growing phenomenon native
advertising allows for everything from
sponsored editorial content that
seamlessly incorporates a brand into a
news article to Instagram influencers
invisibly integrating ads for vitamin
gummies ultimately making the line
between ad and information slash
entertainment all but invisible way more
subtle version of the Texaco show
content marketing
has exploded with corporations producing
their own magazines games and of course
viral videos often focused on addressing
consumer needs as seen in the lows fixed
in six home-improvement as increasingly
we're consuming advertising without
realizing or in spite of it being
advertising possibly the best example of
a 21st century corporation pursuing all
the possibilities of the new age of
advertising can be seen with red bull
which has over the past two decades
checked all the modern marketing boxes
with its own media company that produces
TV magazines music games and more
they've employed everything from
celebrity slash influencer endorsements
to sponsoring music festivals to
acquiring thousands of brand ambassadors
to hand out their product for free they
also host events like breakdancing
competitions and organized social media
stunts like this guy jumping from space
of course the result is a weird
advertiser mediated reality when our
news can be sponsored by JetBlue a
sporting event can be planned and
executed by Red Bull and even Dollar
Shave Club has its own media arm which
to be honest is weirdly good how much of
our culture is just some weird way to
sell you something will there be some
backlash like there was against
sponsored game shows or are we stuck in
this nightmare forever but what do you
guys think let us know in the comments
big big thanks to our patrons and
advertisers for supporting our channel
and podcasts hit that subscribe button
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]